fallout 4 four seasons in a year there's
going to be a joke in there somewhere
right well at the very least there's a
super cool mod that will take your
wastelanders through a full year of
weather Nexus mods user game duchess
created the mod which takes fallout 4 is
day/night cycle to a whole new level you
won't just see the Sun rise and set
you'll see falling snow and blooming
flowers to each season has its own spin
on crops trees and foliage bethesda will
be launching its creation kit later this
year which adds official mod support for
the pc version of the game and will
bring select mods to the console
versions in the future game duchess may
treat the mod and add more options for
jumping between seasons when that
happens in the meantime there are plenty
of other mods to spruce up the
Commonwealth like Macho Man deathclaws
and star wars lightsabers you can check
out both of those and more at Nexus mod
and for all the fallout news you need
keep it gamespot
you